okay
okay
okay
okay
yes
so this uh
um
night
vlog
is
okay
like
foreign
um
okay
pressure on him
obviously not going very well
is
thank you
two minute warning guys
you
um
yes
all right
good afternoon it's an honor to stand uh
here with
house democratic leadership as we
approach the
house democratic caucus issues
conference
at 3 p.m although it will be virtual
as we continue to navigate our way
through the covet 19 pandemic
we're excited we're enthusiastic uh
we're ready to get
to work and continue the process of
delivering
for the american people these are
certainly
challenging times but in america we've
encountered many challenging times
year after year decade after decade
century
after century america is a resilient
country
america is a great country we've come a
long way but of course we still
have a long way to go there are
issues that we need to resolve
on behalf of everyday americans the
framers of the constitution
did not promise a perfect country
in fact we know that they were imperfect
individuals
themselves but they did set us
on a course an aspirational course
for a more perfect union and that is
what
the issues conference in 2021
will be all about how do we
build back better for the people
and create justice opportunity
and prosperity in every single
zip code we look forward to a very
robust conversation
and dialogue with practitioners
activists academics community leaders
and high-ranking governmental officials
including
the president of the united states the
vice president
the secretary of state the former
secretary of state
who was the climate envoy as well as
the current governor of the state of new
mexico
our former colleague in the house of
representatives
we're going to be focused on continuing
the work
that we have already been delivering on
but doing it in the context
of the crises that we confront
building a better economy
that is centered around everyday
americans
addressing systemic racism in a manner
that brings to life
the principle of liberty and justice for
all
making sure that all americans have
access to safe
high quality affordable
health care fixing our broken
immigration
system in a manner that is consistent
with our status as a nation of
immigrants
and of course the rule of law and
finally confronting
the climate crisis in a manner that
recognizes
the existential threat that is posed
to our country our continent
and to the entire world so we're looking
forward
uh to proceeding together
over the next few days and they're
continuing
to work toward building back better
uh for the people the house democratic
caucus is a wonderful orchestra
we've got incredibly talented
legislative
musicians but it wouldn't work
in the absence of a fabulous conductor
nancy d'alessandro pelosi
thank you so much i didn't know where
you were going there i didn't know if we
had to
sing or play some music thank you very
much mr chairman thanks to you
and vice chair aguilar for bringing us
together for this important
issues conference a time of reflection
a time for us to listen and to learn
about some of the challenges that we
face and some of the solutions
that go with them to listen to our
colleagues
the various enthusiasms that they have
and how we can channel them into
building back better for the people
advancing justice opportunity and
prosperity
in every zip code prosperity
for all americans now when we begin our
conference we usually begin with a
prayer and i'm sure that we
will but i will just talk about
i had the chance to go to church this
weekend for the first time in a very
long time
i got on the list
for a holy trinity church
and the gospel this weekend was about
the transfiguration of christ
christ takes peter james and john
to the top of the mountain elijah
appears moses appeared
and god appears and said this is my
beloved son and one
i won't go into the whole gospel but
when
when it's over and they go down the
mountain god says jesus says to james
john and peter don't tell any of the
others what you saw
elijah etc there
until i have risen from the dead and
they're like what i mean we
we just saw elijah now you're talking
about dying and rising but
but the whole point of the gospel was
that in order
to learn we have to unlearn
certain things and that's how i was
thinking of this
how do we
open our minds to the new
to the entrepreneurial thinking that is
out there
to help us do to find a common ground
to understand other points of view
in a way that saves time
but also makes progress so we really
have been looking forward
to even before sunday's possible uh to
this time
of listening learning
reflection on learning so that we can
learn
we can learn more it's very very
important to us
and it happens at a time as the
distinguished chair has indicated
a time when we have a new president of
the united states
joseph biden a new vice president kamala
harris and
we'll be honored with the secretary of
state and other
leaders from this administration but
we're listening at that level
and at the grassroots level and at the
member level
so that we can be transfixed
transformed when we leave in a few a
couple of days
and have a fresh eyes on the subject
that we're out to see
but always true to our values
build back better for the people
advancing justice opportunity and
prosperity
for every zip code in that spirit i
yield to the distinguished gentleman
from maryland a distinguished house
democratic leader mr hoyer
let me say it's always a privilege to
follow the right reverend conductor of
the democratic house
[Laughter]
i have a sort of a mundane role that
i've been assigned and that is to tell
you what we're doing and what we're
going to do
and we will do it in short one minute
five minutes now nancy and i have the
the the ability to talk a little longer
than that
but what these issue conferences are
about
are talking longer more thoughtfully
more interface more discussion as
opposed to
one-minute statements and it is too
as nancy points out the speaker points
out
to look more in depth at the issues we
confront
now the 117th congress is facing one of
the most daunting
scenarios that we've seen we faced
dawning some areas the last time we were
in the majority
in 2009 2007
but 2008 we had the great recession and
we needed to respond
and we did so in a very very decisive
way
and it made a difference which is why we
have one of the
great growth patterns starting in 2010
because of that bill
that we passed and much of that had been
discussed in previous issue conferences
mr chairman
i had the privilege for five and a half
years of being chairman of the caucus
so i know how important these
conferences are
and i know the work that goes into it
and pete uh thank you very much
uh for your leadership and catherine of
course you were involved in these
until you became the assistant speaker
so thank you as well
jim clyburn and i have been around for a
long time so we've been to a lot of
these well he helped one too
as short as possible
uh the house is off to a very good start
we're following a very productive
congress
in the 116th for the house of
representatives i continue to remind
people
the fact that it met a slam door
in the united states senate did not mean
that what we did wasn't a very
productive
and very frankly we passed five bills
which kept us out of depression
and assisted in confronting covet 19.
this week we're taking action on hr1
which is on the floor today
we're going to pass the justice and
policing act the chairman talked about
systemic racism
that is a very key part of our response
over the next two weeks we'll pass the
pro act to make sure that working men
and women have the right to organize and
bargain collectively
so that they can get a fair shake we're
going to
we're going to look at gun violence
background checks in charleston loophole
which is led by jim clyburn
uh 90 of america supports that bill
90 of that or about 86 supported when we
sent it
to the senate in the last congress and
it met a
no way response important women's issues
as well
uh this month is women's history month
we're going to pass the equal rights
amendment the violence against women act
uh reauthorization we're also going to
deal with immigration
the dream act obeyed 85 percent
of the americans support that so we are
doing the people's agenda
and we'll pass that over to the senate
as we look ahead to the remainder of
2021
we'll have a lot of work to do on behalf
of the american people much of which we
will discuss
over these next two days as the theme of
our issue conference says we will be
focused on
building back better
that has a lot of applications but
essentially it means
we want to come back from the crisis
that we have confronted
and come back better and we will do that
that means over the course of this year
we will be looking at and the chairman
mentioned a number of these issues
uh rebuilding infrastructure tackling
climate change strengthening access to
affordable health care
expanding economic opportunity
addressing systemic racism
this issues conference will feature
important conversations
of some of the most pressing issues we
face we'll be hearing from experts in
many fields as we have in the past so i
want to thank chairman jeffries
uh vice chairman pete aguilar
and all of the leadership that has
worked so hard to get us to today
and get us to tomorrow get us through
116th congress in such a productive way
and i predict the 117th congress is
going to be one of the
most productive congresses in which i
have participated thank you very much mr
chairman
and mr bite sentence and i will now
yield to
my dear friend who apparently is going
to give a brief talk
jim clyburn thank you very much mr
leader i promise to be a little more
brief than yours
mr chairman mr vice chair
uh speaker pelosi the assistant speaker
my job is going to be rather easy
this evening throughout this conference
for some reason
and i think i know the reason why
uh i have decided to add
a b word to this buildback better
bold boldly
i think it's come to a surprise of a lot
of people
that president biden
has uh put forth
such a bold client but we should not
have
be surprised because when he received
the nomination
he did something to demonstrate his
ability
to go bold he named
the first woman
to be vice president of these united
states
many have been proposed before
but in this instance he picked not just
a woman but he picked a woman of color
and i know
our history well enough to know that a
woman of color
has been proposed before but not by
a major party and when he did so
he went beyond
what a lot of people would expect he
picked a woman
from a historical black college and
university
and it demonstrated something about him
that i think helps define this
administration and define
what this caucus is going to be like for
the rest of this congress
and on throughout his administration and
that
is to see what needs to be done
and irrespective of what may have been
the past irrespective of what may
be tradition just track out and do it
and do it in such a way that would you
create a climate
for the that is positive for the
american people
so tonight my job is going to be to
introduce i suspect i hope at this point
to present um
kamala harris uh to bring
an address to this caucus and address it
i think
uh we'll say exactly
what we are all about as a caucus
i'm very fond of this
effort because i think
it defines diversity
in a way that we would like to see it
define not just
african-american but asian-american
not just a woman
but also the daughter of immigrants
and not just uh one who has
been uh credentialed
but one who cares with that prudential
regents
uh and credit uh
the historical nature of what a lot of
us have been all about
in this great country as many of you
know i have been uh talking for the last
two years
about the challenge we have as
americans and i have been invoking uh
the writings of alexis of tocqueville in
doing so
and the talkville as many of you know
came to this country that started our
penal system
but when he got here he found a certain
magic about the country
and he set out to find out what the
magic was he came to the conclusion
that america is great not because it's
more enlightened than any other
nation but rather because it has always
been able to repair
its faults this administration
and this congress would take some bold
steps
to repair some significant faults
that have erupted in our society and i
think we're going to do it
in such a way that american people will
be pleased and we look forward to the
future
with great aspirations with that
i'll yield to the distinguished
assistant
speaker catherine clark
thank you so much it is so good to be
with you and
i want to thank chairman jeffries vice
chair aguilar
for putting together this issues
conference
and for all your leadership in in
keeping our caucus
informed and moving forward to meet this
moment
and to our outstanding speaker pelosi
majority leader hoyer
and whip clyburn for their commitment
to making sure that those issues that
families at home
talk about around their kitchen table
are the priorities
on the table here in congress
so justice opportunity and prosperity
in every zip code it is a a
long title for a big piece of work
that we are undertaking to meet this
moment
of racial economic and climate
justice this is the theme of our
conference
and it is the driving force behind our
work in congress
this pandemic has exposed so many of the
inequities that we knew
existed and brought them in to stark
relief
women are being pushed out of the
workforce one out of four women
have lost their jobs families on the
poverty line
are slipping further into despair black
and brown americans
are getting sick and dying at
disproportionate rates
this time of great challenge calls for
great
progress and this is what we're going to
be discussing
at the issues conference this year this
is our moment not to return
to the status quo but to boldly
build back better when workers
are treated with dignity when women
are treated equitably and americans no
matter their background
skin color or geography have equal
access to opportunity this is how we
center
our work in congress this is the
exciting plans that we have in place
to see and help the american people meet
this challenge
and we are so grateful to be able to do
it with the biden
harris administration so we're looking
forward to the next few days
and to the session ahead to deliver on
our promise
to help meet this moment in american
history
and i am now very proud to introduce
vice
chairman of the caucus pete aguilar
thank you assistant speaker clark uh as
the chairman mentioned and he gave you
a rundown of our issues conference
building back better boldly
for the people justice opportunity
prosperity in every zip code
mr clyburn doesn't know that we had the
banner made already so now
it'll be delayed because of the printing
our conference is built on the diversity
of our caucus
not only are we a diverse caucus but
we're a united
caucus we showed that with the american
rescue plan we're going to build off of
that
to address and to discuss issues of the
economy
and health care and opportunity
in making sure that americans have a
chance in our communities
but we will do that and the conference
was built off of
the diversity of the members of our
caucus
who were given time to give us ideas and
suggestions
on programs that will help them
so that's the mindset that we'll take
into this into this issues conference
is building off of our relationships
with our colleagues
learning from the diversity of that
caucus
and that's what will continue to be our
guide throughout the
throughout the issues conference mr
chairman
we have to prepare for a timely three
o'clock start but we do have an
opportunity to take a few questions
if you could talk about this chairman
and also madam you would address it as
well
i just wondering how concerned you are
with the white house in their role in
the passage of the 50
minimum wage do you feel that president
biden has offered
a true strategy to making that happen
especially given
the ruling by the parliamentarian
well i'll just briefly say that the
administration put forth
a transformative american rescue plan
it contained the 15 minimum wage we
believe that that is the right
approach as evidenced by the fact that
it was in the legislation that we passed
but the house is the house and the
senate is the senate
they have a process they have a
parliamentarian uh
and i'm not going to speak on what their
process
will yield other than to say as i think
the speaker has made clear
we're committed to making sure that we
raise the minimum wage to 15
per hour it's the wealthiest country in
the history of the world
the notion that anyone is working
full-time
trying to raise a family and making 7.25
cents should not be acceptable to anyone
in the united states of america
the fight for 15 is one that many of us
have been involved in for a few years
and just because this may not survive
the senate right now
doesn't mean that that fight is anywhere
near over
so we will continue to use whatever
legislative options are available to us
it is wildly popular among the american
people
in a bipartisan nonpartisan way
democrats republicans
independence and the rest support
raising the minimum wage
i come to this with experience uh when
sending mr clyburn and i
raised the minimum wage in 2006.
well we we won in 2006 he passed in 2007
in the first 100 hours not days
hours of the co of that new majority
that we had
we passed it 7 25 an hour it hadn't been
raised
in 11 years and now it's been a long
time since it has been raised and we are
determined
to get the job done for the american
people
this pathetic minimum wage seven and a
quarter
all these years later is really a gift
to underwrite those who will not who are
exploiting their workers in many
respects some people just can't afford
businesses
just can't afford to pay the full
fifteen dollars and we want to help them
but by and large that people are getting
food stamps they're getting medicaid
they're getting
housing assistance in the rest because
their employers are not paying a decent
wage so again
for the taxpayer to save money from all
those expenditures
for the workers so that they can put
food on the table
when they work full time and for the
businesses
especially the small businesses uh that
need help
in meeting that goal we will be passing
middle age and the pre the white house
was right out there with it
very early we have no complaint about
what they have done
but there's clearly members of your
conference that are very concerned that
this particular opportunity
is your best opportunity including many
of your progressive members
that this is our best opportunity right
passing it through reconciliation
well we'll have other reconciliation
we'll have on the reconciliation
but let me just say this because i think
this is really important
this bill this as mr uh
ref this bill this american
rescue plan is spectacular
it has so much in it to put vaccinations
in the arms the american people
money in the pockets of our families
children in school workers
in jobs this is excellent so let's not
be diverted into thinking of what's not
in but let's respect it for what is in
and it is spectacular now we were also
present
in 2009 the house had a bill that was
1.1
trillion dollars the senate cut it back
300 billion dollars and people say what
lesson did you learn by not going big
enough
no we did go big enough but it was cut
back by
about a third little more than a third
when it went over to the senate side
in order to get bipartisan support
we value that but if we had stayed big
we would have had a bigger recovery then
this is a big bill for a bigger repel
recovery in fact in light of an a
pandemic
just what this country needs it meets
the needs of the american people
we have some other questions we're not
going to have a conversation
i issued a statement on this issue and
made clear that these allegations are
very serious
against governor cuomo made by serious
individuals
and deserve a serious and independent
investigation
now that the attorney general has taken
over the investigation
it will be fully independent and
thorough and i await
the results of that
a
investigation
um you guys are going into this
conference um
sort of the legislative tempo with uh
adding another work week
um how much of that is sort of
um it's basically in response to the
ghost of 1994
and 2010 when you lost
the chambers well i'm going to yield to
the speaker and standing on the schedule
but obviously i think as jim indicated
these are challenging times and so we're
going to
act in a bold fashion and in order to be
able to do that we have to get to work
not fly off to florida
but actually get to work
for the people because the level of pain
and suffering
and death that they are experiencing
is extraordinary and that's the only
thing that's driving us
let me say it has nothing to do with 94.
uh has nothing to do with 2006.
it has to do with 2020 and 2021 and the
challenges we face from cobit 19
which demand action systemic racism
demands action uh infrastructure
investment demands action
i i can go into a lot of the other
issues that i mentioned earlier but
jim clyburn would say i would speak too
long so
it has nothing to do with that it has to
do with what's in front of us
and dealing with it so that the people
know that we're there fighting for them
and their families their children
their future
um thank you uh fbi director
christopher wray this morning testified
there testified about a number of
ongoing investigations still related to
january 6.
very specifically if you have heard
anything or if you can give us any sort
of insight into
the investigation into current members
of congress uh giving alleged force is
that still happening
are you being captured
well as you may be aware some
of our members saw some
people here the day before
january 6th it was at a time when we
were told not to even bring
family members to the capitol because
there would be no
uh tours or or taking our families
around
but yet these people were there and they
had to be there as the guest of a member
or staff of a member's office so
those members who saw
those people have conveyed what they saw
to law enforcement and they're looking
into that
they feel comfortable that they uh
what what they conveyed is being
addressed
that's all i can say about that thank
you guys for both yourselves
uh i wanted to focus on you hr one and
then the george
floyd police adapter being bought up
again so i wonder how is it different
from
last congress to this congress because
when you go to the senate
you still need 60 votes 60 votes still
are
apparently there and so have democrats
maybe
oversold what they could accomplish with
control
of both chambers no i'll let everybody
jump in on this but i mean i think
we we have a house democratic majority
we have we have a change in occupancy at
1600 pennsylvania avenue
the the the king of obstruction is no
longer
in charge in the senate it's a very
different landscape
handed to us by the american people
because they want things done
like defending our democracy hr1
or transforming policing in a way that
brings the police and the community
together
and lifts up the principle of equal
protection under the law
let me make a comment uh
because this seems to be a theme of
the press and and some others that
we we said we're going to do x y and z
but we didn't say we were going to be
magicians we didn't say we could
magically make the
senate change or the house change and we
have a very close majority you see that
we're doing exactly what we said we're
going to do
successfully uh i am one who believes
that the filibuster is an
undemocratic uh utilized
in my early generation when i started in
an interest in public affairs to
undermine the rights of citizens of
color in america
i think the filibuster ought to be
modified the founders wanted the senate
to be able to talk and be more
thoughtful and
sort of as they said cool the hot
broth into the saucer but we can't
magically
uh make the republicans be
for what the people are for that was my
point the people
overwhelmingly for the agenda were
passing
and democracy works and so if the people
want those bills to pass
they will either demand that we do away
with the filibuster or demand
that some republican senators who refuse
to vote for what the people want
leave office but we're going to do
everything in our power i think chuck
schumer is going to do everything in his
power
to make sure that the agenda that we are
working on
and promise the people will in fact be
the agenda that we put
forward and hopefully pass
none of you here would have predicted
seven republican votes
for conviction none of us
in this room yet we got there so we'll
keep talking to our republican
colleagues and to
keep working with them both in the house
and in the senate
to get our agenda done because we
believe that is what the people want us
to do
i can't help but excuse mr clement
well i think that uh
all of you know i hail from south
carolina
um i've studied history all of my life
my dad made me start studying history
when i was eight years old i remember
harry truman and
tom to do it and i've stayed in close
touch with history i remember 1957 i was
a high school
graduate i graduated high school in
1957.
a lot of people think the strom thurman
filibustered
the civil rights act they think about
1964.
it was a 1957 civil rights act which was
nothing but a principle
and the filibuster was used to kill that
and we've seen it used throughout time
now i'm calling on the american people
but i'm also calling on my friends in
the senate i think all of you that
been watching things for the last
several days you see
that our republican colleagues
are now adhering to
political philosophies that are
throwback
to the 1940s and 50s and they are using
the filibuster
to deny progress
basically to low-income people
and if they're going to use the
filibuster to deny
the minimum wage increase it would be
tantamount
to using it to deny civil
rights and that to me is what we're
going to be talking about going forward
we're not going to just
give in to these arcade
methods of denying progress
this party is not going to do it
and if they want to be categorized
that way we will oblige them
i can tell you i will not be quiet on
this
issue people of color will not be quiet
on this issue we are not
going to allow the filibuster
that was used to deny me
and people who look like me the
opportunity to come to this congress
and that's what they did and they're not
going to deny
the opportunity for people to make a
decent living
above the poverty wage if that's what
they're going to do
they're going to have to live with it
because we're going to make sure that we
serve it up
i couldn't resist uh coming to the
podium when you asked about
hr1 because as we gather here
on the floor of the house that
legislation
is being debated as we speak
and that legislation is called the
for the people bill h.r 1.
in the senate it's s-1 so we're very
pleased that they have embraced the
spirit of that
this is something that is enormously
popular among the american people
the american people want to reduce the
role of big
dark special interest money in politics
which is preventing
so many good things from happening the
people want to see
an end to voter suppression the first
300 pages of the bill
were written by john lewis to end voter
suppression
the people want to see
redistricting done like by commission so
that
voters are choosing their elected
officials not their elected officials
choosing their voters the people want to
see a stronger
voice for people at the grassroots level
small donors and and grassroots
people in every in every way mobilizing
money
uh messaging in every way the list goes
on and on the people
want to see an end to the foreign
influence in our elections that's one of
the most popular features
of hr1 so as you've heard me say perhaps
you haven't but
others have here lincoln said public
sentiment is everything with it you can
accomplish almost anything
without it practically nothing public
sentiment is there democrats
republicans independence just declines
to state people not particularly even
engaged in the political arena but this
bill
is when the people say they want this
this and this this bill
is for the people so it's pretty
exciting but you asked this question
right when that bill was being debated
on the floor of the house last night we
had a call with
eric holder and john sarbanes and
zoe lofgren and and uh
monday jones our new member freshman
member
with our grassroots organization around
the country and as we were on that
call the rule on the bill was being
debated
people were very excited they could
almost see
history in motion this is essential
for us to return
the people's house at steny began
for well through explore speech i think
you begin government other people by the
people
and for the people it's pretty exciting
we're going to
make it happen and we're going to make
it happen because the public
will insist upon it and it and it uh
it's going to make all the difference in
the world
for the people i think that's it
just before we leave i'm going to share
one thing about this week i
uh it occurred to me when i went back to
my seat at noon today
i watched the live streaming of the
unveiling of a monument
across the street from the capitol in
columbia south carolina
from the state house on this day
march 2nd 60 years ago i was arrested on
that corner
along with 191 others 189 of us were
found guilty
of wanting to sit down at a lunch
counter
all i'm saying to you is nobody thought
that day that one of those little 20
year olds
wrestling that day would be standing
here today
we are not going to give up on this we
are going to fight
to give people a decent salary
get people decent housing get people
justice and if the other side
want to spend their time wallowing
in the past be going to
do what's necessary to highlight it's a
monument